[Musique]
bon sens à tous sera vite vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7 8 et qu une
édition particulière consacré aux idées
de cadeaux pour les fêtes de fin d'année
conçu à saint quentin en yvelines
tout de suite le sommaire des
gourmandises fabriqué à saint quentin en
yvelines vue et bonbons caramels
noisettes chocolat ou praliné une
farandole de saveurs pour les produits
de la société caramel découverte dans
cette édition stage d'équitation balade
en paddleboard ou carte d'accès au golf
les offres pour noël de lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
nous recevons robin marcelli responsable
commercialisation du site pour nous
détailler tous ces cadeaux géolocaliser
son animal de compagnie poursuivre son
activité
c'est la solution localise développé par
m2m au ski cube une technologie relié à
une application dans cette édition nous
recevons aussi valérie olek directrice
d'euro france
elle viendra nous parler d'un téléphone
destiné aux seniors
la période des fêtes de fin d'année un
moment gourmand
l'occasion de découvrir des différents
produits gustatifs
c'est ce que propose l'entreprise
guyancourt toise caramel des bonbons des
chocolats ou encore des bûches des
produits vendus dans une boutique à
paris et sur internet
nous nous sommes rendus dans l'atelier
de fabrication à guyancourt regardez
c'est le willy wonka guyancourt toi
comme ce personnage fictif nicolas lewin
possède sa chocolaterie la spécialité de
ce chef pâtissier le caramel sous toutes
ses formes avec des touches de chocolat
pour apporter des saveurs différentes
tout cela dans des coffrets cadeaux
comme les caramels à tartiner des
caramels boom des macarons aussi on
vient de sortir une collection de
macarons tout à base de caramel caramel
aux fruits caramels au chocolat là pour
noël on a des petits sachets de friture
donc on peut avoir des petits sachets de
qaraqosh donc les cartes c'est un
morceau de caramels bonbons de chocolat
donc ici on a des caractères noirs on a
des nouilles les new girl à sésame
on peut aussi retrouver les premiers
niveaux bien sûr mais encore près d'un
corps près de 10 prime et la magie de
noël opère aussi à traverser bûche avec
une création spéciale pour 2018
une bus roulent et traditionnelle mais
avec avec pas mal de techniques à
l'intérieur beaucoup de textures
l'acidité du citron qui envoie du peps
et la noisette qui vient un petit peu a
rapporté de la gourmandise à la bûche
pour les plus gourmands nicholas lewin a
prévu cette bûche caramel cacahuètes
on est vraiment dans la gourmandise la
cacahuètes grillées salle et qu'on
travaille en plusieurs états dans un
biscuit dans un crémeux est le tout avec
une mousse caramel vanillé et phare de
sel durant le dernier mois de l'année
caramel réalise près de 200000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires au mois de janvier
place à la galette des rois au menu une
frangipane au morceau d'amendé occupe de
caramel fondu puis une galette citron
noisette
autre rendez vous au mois de janvier
pour l'entreprise caramel le salon du
chocolat à tokyo au japon à partir du 18
janvier
l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines regorge de cadeaux pour en
parler nous accueillons robin marcelli
en plateau bonsoir bonsoir
alors lille de loisirs c'est un espace
d'activités familiales
alors quelles sont les idées de cadeaux
on va commencer peut-être par les
enfants alors pour les enfants bon on a
pas mal d'activités 1 qui peuvent être
proposées aux enfants sur les loisirs et
pour noël pour les idées de cadeaux on a
notamment le centre qu'est-ce qui a
commencé par exemple les activités à
partir de 3 ans qui lance alors par le
biais aussi de la fédération française
d'équitation no good et des petits
chèques cadeaux qui peut être offerts
dont des chèques cadeaux comme comme
celui ci hamon qui s'envolent tort à
l'écran peut-être très simplement up
bien sûr de le montrer à l'écran donc
alors ce sera donc des chèques cadeaux
qui se forme comme celui-ci qui peuvent
être récupérées à l'accueil du centre
équestre donc auprès de sky équitation
et qui peuvent être ensuite utilisées
pour des baptêmes poneys des stages
d'équitation en plusieurs fois ou en une
seule fois peut être complétée d'air
avec des financements un autre donc ça
ses ventes pour l'équitation ensuite
pour les enfants et même brûle tout le
le tout public vous avez le golf le golf
alors le do in asia le prouve en parlait
justement jusqu'à golf blue green
oui au sein de votre espace deux
parcours 18 trous
oui un compact citroën practice qu'est
ce que vous proposez justement pour pour
tester ce parcours alors pour tester le
parcours vous avez plusieurs
possibilités vous avez déjà de
nombreuses portes ouvertes à l'année
donc la porte ouverte c'est l'entrée
gratuite donc pas forcément pour le pour
la partie cadeaux mais pour la partie
cadeau si vous voulez offrir du golf du
golfe à noël vous avez deux possibilités
vous avez une carte qui a été mise en
place par blue green cette annexe
plantes comme comme ceux ci et qui vous
permet d'avoir des add d'acquérir des
points pour le practice donc récupéré un
nombre de balles un nombre de points et
plus vous mettez entre l'iemed dessous
plus vous avez de points en proportion
est plus vous pouvez pratiquer
l'activité de golf et la deuxième
possibilité ça va être de prendre des
cours donc une initiation 4h30
d'initiation donc une opération qui
durera jusqu'au 31 décembre donc vont
profiter assez rapidement c'est parfait
pour les fêtes ça va être d'offrir
quatre heures 30 initiation en groupe
pour l'année donc c'est valable pour
l'année 2019 mais vous pouvez acheter
cette initiation à 49 euros au lieu de
59 euros jusqu'au 31 décembre
donc ça c'est pour une promotion pour
une nouvelle mission pour noël pour les
fêtes de fin d'année pour découvrir
cette activité et à partir du 1er
janvier c'est le prix se changera du
coup alors là c'est la politique globale
de bluegreen en tout cas jusqu'au 31
décembre cette offre est valable
ensuite il peut y avoir des options mais
pour aujourd'hui en tout cas on est
vraiment sûr sur cette offre la cdm
informations qu'on peut retrouver
jusqu'au sur le site aulas il va
s'afficher en bas de l'écran comment se
porte l'île de loisirs au niveau
économique au niveau économique il doit
dire alors on est là on est en fin de
saison les bilans sont pas sortis
personnellement je n'ai pas mangé par on
n'a pas fait le tour des activités
on a eu une saison qui a été qui a été
marquée par un très bel été donc avec
beaucoup de visiteurs sur les activités
que voilà qui ont tourné voilà c'est en
savoir plus de chiffres que ça vous
communiquer à vous communiquer
aujourd'hui ma demande et on est
toujours dans le développement dans
l'objectif dans l'optique d'accueillir
toujours plus de monde donc on développe
on a pour objectif de développer des
activités des offres envers les usagers
pour qu'ils puissent venir essayer
découvrir profiter de cet espace et les
activités qui sont proposées
dernière question qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour l'année 2019 un très
bel été comme celui qu'on a eu un très
beau printemps un beau très belle année
vraiment c'est un parc de pleine nature
avant tout donc du beau temps et après
les gens peuvent venir profiter du parc
autant qu'il le souhaite merci robin
marcelli d'être venu sur notre plateau
je le rappelle responsable
commercialisation de l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
merci et on reste sur les cadeaux
sportifs au pied du sapin avec la
société all tricks elle est née il ya
une dizaine d'années dans les yvelines à
voisins le bretonneux spécialisée dans
le vélo le running et l'outdoor présente
dans les commerces l'entreprise a ouvert
une boutique à coignières un reportage
de manon varaldo dans cette boutique
ronning cyclisme et outdoor les fêtes de
noël se prépare le vélo reste un des
cadeaux les plus souhaités
ils représentent environ 90% de leur
activité typiquement pour la période de
noël c'est un cadeau qui est assez
plébiscité surtout ils veulent enfoncer
un peu leur première liberté
donc vous allez là des vélos de
différentes marques
en termes de prix bas on démarre à moins
de 200 euros pour aller sur un 24 pouces
à plus de 500 euros le mois de décembre
représente entre 10 à 15 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires
on remarque qu'en décembre on a souvent
affaire à des clients qui cherchent des
produits plaisir donc ça peut être des
montres connecter avec gps des vélos
pour les enfants à retrouver au pied du
sapin de noël et des produits qui sont
innovants notamment liées à la sécurité
en vélo la particularité de cet
éclairage là c'est qu'il fait aussi
office de radars donc c'est un produit
qui va dicter les véhicules à 150 mètres
du cycliste et qui va lui donner la
progression sur un écran soit sur
l'écran qui est fournie ou soit ça va
être connecté directement sur un an
un conteur gps de la même marque ce
produit est sur le marché depuis deux
ans un cadeau pour noël d'une valeur de
139 euros
mais la sécurité n'a pas de prix pour
ses proches une idée cadeau
technologique avec un système de
géolocalisation pour chat ou pour chiens
une solution développée par la start-up
m2m installé dans l'incubateur ce cube
depuis 2015 les images sont signés
marylène iapichino suivre son chat ou
son chien à la trace c'est possible
grâce à ce dispositif
un boîtier de géolocalisation attaché
sur le collier de l'animal est relié à
l'application my localise son origine
une étude sur les différences de
comportement des chats ruraux et urbains
le projet part d'une étude scientifique
exactement
donc on a développé ce produit avec des
fonctionnalités particulières
concrètement ça sert à suivre son chat à
savoir où il va
la nuit
alors est-ce qu'il chassait ce qu'elle a
un amoureux 11 le boîtier de
géolocalisation allumé le suivi peut
commencer sur l'application avec
différents modes une petite fenêtre
s'ouvre avec le mode poursuite la
position les lumières et le niveau de
batterie également quand j'appuie sur le
mode poursuite
ici il me propose de donner mais je me
mets données de localisation je fais ok
et j'ai directement mois la position
vers mon chat le repérage fonctionne
grâce au système gps ou aux réseaux wi
fi un système intégré et configurée par
la société vous avez une puce gps
vous avez une carte sim industriels que
nous avons intégré directement en usine
depuis le début de la commercialisation
en janvier 2018 une centaine de boîtiers
sont en fonctionnement
actuellement la start up compte près de
250 clients dans le monde animalier
on reste dans le domaine du high-tech
avec notre nouvel invité
bonsoir valérie olé vous êtes directrice
de doro france basée à
montigny-le-bretonneux alors déjà un mot
sur ce que ces d'euros c'est une société
donc suédoise spécialisée dans les tôles
et télécommunications comment se passe
votre activité en france mais côté très
bien en fait on est implanté dans
l'agglomération depuis l'an 2000
donc ça va faire dix neuf ans très
bientôt et donc on s'est beaucoup
développée ces dernières années
notamment en se spécialisant sur le
segment des seniors puisque en matière
de téléphonie effectivement il existe
est très très peu d'offres réellement
adaptée pour nos parents et nos grands
parents et justement ça peut être des
idées de cadeaux pour noël avec
plusieurs produits oui alors en fait on
est on va dire historiquement un petit
peu plus connus pour ce type de produit
donc les téléphones vraiment très simple
d'utilisation très visuel avec donc
l'ergonomie d'un clapet qui permet de
protéger le clavier et la touche d'appel
d'urgence en cas de problème
c'est des produits qu'on va encore
beaucoup et on ne néglige pas les
personnes qui n'ont pas envie d'avoir un
smartphone pour autant évidemment on
pense aussi
à ceux qui ont envie effectivement de
s'ouvrir vers les nouvelles technologies
d'avoir le même type de produit on va
dire que leur enfant en font donc voilà
d'être d'avoir la chance d'être d'être
inclus dans un groupe de familles
whatsapp messenger facebook etc et donc
on a conçu des produits de dernière
génération smartphones avec complètement
adapté à la fois je dirais pour des gens
qui ont peut-être déjà eu un smartphone
par le passé mais qui ont besoin
aujourd'hui d'avoir un produit qui a une
qualité de son exceptionnelle claire
cuisse en compatible avec les appareils
auditifs
on va retrouver aussi sur ce type de
produits la touche d'appel d'urgence en
cas de souci donc effectivement c'est un
produit qui est certifiée google qui va
offrir toutes les fonctionnalités d'un
produit standard du marché avec la
petite touche en plus de deux ans et
cette touche en plus c'est effectivement
une interface que l'on a développé de
manière vraiment spécifique pour
notamment les personnes qui veulent
débuter avec donc une interface
étonnamment simple de navigation très
pédagogique très développée dago gic
alors si on veut montrer par exemple
comment comment ça ça se présente sous
par exemple prenons l'exemple vous
voulez envoyer une photo à votre fils
et bien tout simplement gardant votre
écran vous allez avait appuyé donc sur
envoyer une fois oui sur la droite de
l'écran
voilà donc qu'est ce que vous voulez
envoyer un message un e-mail une photo
mais vous allez cliquer sur une photo
vous arrivez directement sur votre
galerie vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
demander où sont stockés vos photos donc
vous choisissez celles que vous voulez
on va vous demander à qui un contact de
votre de votre galerie par exemple
thomas sur son mobile et vous n'avez
plus qu'à envoyer votre photo en soit en
joignant un texte ou et et vous avez la
possibilité également de dicter votre
texte ne sait pas toujours évident de la
de taper
de taper son texte c'est quelque chose
que qui répond à la demande du marché
c'est les seniors ont plus envie
d'utiliser ce type d'outil oui de plus
en plus de plus en plus ça c'est quelque
chose que l'on que l'on voit se
développer c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
interroge un une personne de 65 ans et
plus sur quel sera son prochain
téléphone aujourd'hui à plus de 60 % ils
vont répondre un smartphone alors
conclure les coups de frein combien
coûtent ces deux produits alors là on
est sur un produit à 199 euros
celui-ci à 79 euros des produits que
vous pouvez retrouver sur le site
internet qui va s'afficher en bas de
l'écran
valérie olek merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau parisien c'est la fin de ce
numéro merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous souhaite d'excellentes fêtes et une
bonne année 2010 9 retour de l'actualité
économique en janvier à bientôt sur tv
[Musique]